>>> HE CALLS HIMLF D
RDF DIVI
76 OFG IN THEEAKEY LARGO,
PART OF HIS RESEARCH IS WHAT
LIVIFEAT
THE HUONORTH
BE ON YOUR SHOW.THANK YOU SODO
THN BODYD HYPOTHWOD TT EASE OKED
TESTS CAME BACK AN YH,'STR EVER
HAS BEEN SO MUCHR.DEEP IREM SLEE
WE'RE VERY EXCIT AGNIFICANT.
>> WHAT ARE THOUK ARE COBU T
RFAC ?IGUS
, IT'S THE SECOND NCES THAT COM
BEING IN AG  ENVIRONMEIGANRBARI
POUNDS PER SQUARENCH WHICH HY ,
>>G SOME OF
DAILE,
THROUGH WHISIKTHROUGHOUT THE DAD
.5A.BEUSM AN EARLY
GOTTEN UP EARLY AND FAULT.
E HER. AF COFFEE AND
SC NOT HAPPEN WITHOUCOEEOING EKO
S ON DAILD I'M TRYINGUTINEXTREC
SO I S IN THTUBE FORAYO
EXPERIME TO FIGUREUT
STUCK
>> WHAT OTHEULD BECALF E E NEEDA
YONESEARCHS O WHAT ARE THE OTHER
EXPERIENCE?
THIWAA
TOTALLY  CONSEQUENCE IEM
WE ARE SO EXCITED ABOUTHAT.
WE'VE REACHED OVERPERSON OVE CA
AN PEJUVENE
RI
TANGR RE DID BETTERE THE
LIKE IN THE WATER. CE CA V AND V
>> SCIENCE IS COOL.
60% REM SLEEP ISOOLL